in Washington police say they're taking
no chances as they get ready for a rally
today in support of the January 6th
Riders who storm the nation's capital
more than 600 people have been charged
for taking part in that deadly assault
of those about 60 are locked up by their
awaiting trial or having already been
convicted this morning fencing that was
removed months after the failed
Insurrection is back up along two
streets running alongside Capitol Hill
Jeff pegaze is there Jeff good morning
good morning Jeff police here putting
the final touches on there a security
plan and that includes putting up
posters like this one notices saying all
firearms prohibited within a thousand
feet of this demonstration and it's
right behind these huge snowplows
obviously not out here to clear the snow
this is part of the security apparatus
in place right across from where the
rally is going to take place you see the
capitol there police in the foreground
you have barricades around and anyone
coming to this demonstration they're
still going to be about a quarter mile
away from the capitol
Capitol Hill is on high alert there are
layers of barricades fencing and
security cameras K-9 units patrolling
nearby Union Station we're not going to
tolerate violence the Capitol Police
Chief acknowledged that violence was a
possibility in your view are those
threats of violence credible we don't
know with any certainty but what we do
know is that
um this the chatter that we heard prior
to January 6th obviously turned out to
be
many of those threats turned out to be
in fact credible it was far less
Security on January 6th and the
resulting attack that wounded more than
100 officers and led to five deaths has
prompted Capitol Police this time around
to deploy every one available Saturday
with 100 National Guard troops on
standby just blocks from the capitol
Capital police say that they are most
concerned about the potential of clashes
between protesters and counter
protesters in my opinion that's the most
likely uh scenario for violence rally
organizer Matt Brainerd a former Trump
campaign staffer says the event which
will include calls for the imprisoned
January six rioters to be released will
be peaceful the Capitol Police know that
we are no threat this is a theater to
deter people from attending but experts
worry that it could serve as a
recruiting event for future violent
activities the thing to watch out for is
the idea that this is a networking
opportunity uh and I think what we need
to worry about is not what just happens
on Saturday but it's how this movement
changes and morphs
and there is also as we mentioned this
big concern about counter protesters
clashes created by counter protesters
who show up here they're expecting about
700 people to show up for the primary
protest the justice for j6 you can see
already police are in place you have
these big barriers with these snow plows
here too they are ready for anything
they don't want any sort of slip UPS uh
similar to what what happened on January
6th so they've done a lot of work a lot
of preparation ahead of this rally
Michelle and it looks like it Jeff thank
you so much